this is a constitutional battle and
we're gonna defend our rights and you're
and you're willing to risk jail for that
absolutely in late 2011 the Obama
administration's Justice Department
initiated a major crackdown on
California's medical marijuana
dispensaries despite repeated promises
to the contrary what I'm not gonna be
doing is using Justice Department
resources to try to circumvent state
laws on this issue that said during the
campaign you'll be surprised to know
will be consistent with what we'll be
doing here in law enforcement at the
time reason TV profile Darren Sandusky
who ran several successful dispensaries
and a grow house in California's Inland
Empire and was shocked to have received
a threatening letter from the Department
of Justice dye turned white shy at the
floor it was unexpected during the
production of that video Sandusky's
operation was shut down all of his
assets seized I got $60 in my pocket
that's it after he and several other
operators took their cases to court they
successfully won injunctions against
cities trying to ban dispensaries and
Sandusky reopened as the case continued
all the way up to the California Supreme
Court but the feds were not happy with
this outcome we've been battling the
city and actually winning cases
including a recent eviction case the g3
won and federal government has stepped
in and shut it all down
Sandusky has spent the last seven weeks
in county prison awaiting a bond hearing
now he's out on bail under house arrest
awaiting trial for federal drug
trafficking charges he agreed to sit
down with reason TV to discuss the
situation in the state of medical
marijuana in California yeah this was my
first time in prison and I was
surrounded by people you know mostly
people who were in for parole violations
and/or possession of drugs or people
that were in violation of parole with
drug violations so I mean we're
populating in our prisons with people
that she really shouldn't be there what
was it like that first night you spent
in jail that was a it was a cold night
it was you know sleeping on a steel bed
and not knowing what's gonna happen
unable to make phone call wondering what
really was going on nobody treats you
through that whole process as if you are
any chance of being innocent you are
guilty till proven innocent it's
unfortunate the federal government is
taking this kind of action against me I
mean I think not only is it an action
against me personally I consider it
aggressive action against everybody in
our state and especially all of those
who were voted for medical marijuana but
they strategically hit people that are I
believe are high-profile cases that they
get the most bang for the buck our case
was being is being heard in front of the
California Supreme Court on whether or
not cities are allowed to ban and go
against the laws that were passed by the
state and so it was a high-profile case
and it was it got a lot of media
attention obviously in taking us down
with our particular situation and our
cooperative we had 50 full-time w2
employees that in one day everybody lost
their their job had to file for
unemployment and lost their medical
benefits 50 employees being put on
unemployment was a $70,000 obligation
now put on the state for no other reason
than local officials requesting this
kind of action from the federal
government during this interview
Sandusky produced a copy of a letter
from uplands mayor Ramos er
requesting help from the Department of
Justice and cracking down on
dispensaries a DOJ official replies
saying the Department of Justice
stated on many occasions that it is
committed to the enforcement of the
Controlled Substances Act this office
will continue to give extra
consideration to communities like yours
that have made it clear that commercial
marijuana operations are unwanted now
that the City Council in Los Angeles
which is home to hundreds of
dispensaries has voted to ban them many
more federal raids could be on the
horizon this is my message to the LA
dispensaries be careful how you move
forward requests are coming from the
city officials who and they are taking
action against those who are pushing the
issue with the city if you're aggressive
with the City Council and city officials
they're going to be aggressive against
you in California we have the right to
enact laws and we have our own
Constitution and under the Tenth
Amendment it provides us protection to
enact those laws this is a
constitutional battle and we're gonna
defend our rights as American citizens
to do what we say we are able to do and
that is pass laws and you're and you're
willing to risk jail for that absolutely
but you've seen the statistics in terms
of federal prosecution success rates
isn't that disheartening is very
disheartening I think the especially
with some of the books that I've read
and time that I was spending in jail
about the about the conviction rates I
find it very disturbing but I think most
of those people end up playing out and
taking deals because they again the
federal government an accusation by the
federal government is a guilty till
proven innocent sentencing for somebody
so not you're not gonna plead out I'm
not pleading out I have no intention of
pleading now I'm not concerned about
that because I'm gonna defend
what I believe is right and if I have to
go to jail for 20 years defending a then
so be it if a jury finds me guilty of
breaking federal law then I'll go do the
time